just because you keep failing and you're
facing one setback after another and you
feel like you're seeing no growth like
that doesn't mean quit it just means
you're just in the thick of it it's just
hard it's hard to blaze new Trail yeah
and it's supposed to it's supposed to be
hard yeah it is it is otherwise everyone
would do it like so you want to have the
the top podcast for people to learn
about the art of comedy and learn about
their favorite comedians yeah a lot of
people would like to have that so you're
going to have to work way harder than
your competition everybody would do it
if it were like I want to make a million
dollars in comedy like yeah we all would
like that you know like we'd all be
doing it if it weren't like the most
hellish slog you can possibly imagine
filled with rejection and closed doors
and bombing and people telling you you
suck and Instagram comments and YouTube
comments like yeah we'd all be doing it
if we didn't have to go through that hot
breath what's goody hot breath of verse
welcome back to Hot Breath the show
where you learn comedy from the pros I
am your host comedian Joel buers and our
guest today is a living success story of
that self-made comedy hustle we talk
about here at hot breath so if you're
aspiring comedian a working comedian or
just a comedy fan in general this show
is for you so subscribe to our YouTube
channel join our email list and our
guest today is going to leave you with
some great gems she is actually software
engineer turned radio host turned
comedian that just a year and a half
into her career self-funded her own soul
out theater tour and now much more so
please welcome to the hot breath of
verse hot bre and sister in the one and
only Jen folweiler everyone thank you so
much I'm a fan of the podcast so it's a
it's a big exciting thing to be here oh
my gosh you're I'm a fan of I subscribe
it's in my feed I love it I love what
you're doing I'm very analytical about
everything I do so I just love the way
you you you get into what are the
mechanisms that makes this all work I'm
super nerdy like that yeah and that's
what I've learned from doing over 400 of
these is like everyone kind of has their
own approach to this game There's No One
Way CU even like what you did a year and
a half in you're like whatever I'm just
G to fund a theater tour like and me I'm
13 years in and I'm like well gez I
didn't how I why didn't I think about
that like so no one has one way but the
fact that you were had even just like
the selfconfidence or awareness to take
that leap craziness is the word you're
looking for there's a little it's a
little bit of craziness there was there
fear involved with that leap or there
was so much fear the okay so the way the
way this works is I cold called theaters
my best friend and I cold called
theaters we would just do a Google
search I would look on Google Maps I
would say Rent theater in let's say
Columbus Ohio so we would Co call them
and say hey can we rent your theater and
they would say uh we don't get a lot of
calls like this they I mean they thought
we were spammers or you know they they
thought that we we were I they didn't
know what to do with with us so I also
found that theaters are half price on
Mondays and Tuesdays so it was pretty
much a Monday Tuesday tour I got a
couple of Wednesdays like B big
excitement when I could get a Wednesday
but I I'd book them on Mondays and
Tuesdays and you have to pay you have to
pay for the full the full price to book
it and so I had over $50,000 on my
personal credit card before I put
tickets on sale and I'd never done
anything like this and my fans only
newly knew me as a stand-up comic I'd
been doing it but they hadn't seen a lot
of it they I was a radio host they knew
me as a Serious XM radio host I will
never forget the night before those
tickets went on sale I was actually in
my bathroom because I I thought I was
going to vomit because I just thought I
can't I've signed contracts I can't get
out of this and if I don't sell tickets
I think I'll still have to do the tour
but with like five people in the front
row I was so terrified um and then and
then things came up like you have to get
event insurance so where do you get
event insurance you have to hire
security I am now licensed to sell
liquor in uh the state of Maryland
because I the theater wouldn't they they
couldn't provide alcohol and I was like
I'm not doing a sober show so so I can
now sell alcohol in Maryland um but it
was it was a thousand times harder than
I thought it would be and I think
sometimes it's a good thing that you
don't know how hard something is and
that's I wouldn't have done it if I had
known how hard it would be but it it all
worked out it yeah every show sold out
in the well two didn't but they were
like 90% so effectively every every show
sold out and we did uh 14 on that how
does that how does that feel I mean were
you just like I'm Invincible like it did
kind of well oh no uh the last show was
mid-February of 2020 so I very quickly
did not feel Invincible but but you know
what interesting is there's I think
there's a great lesson here in trusting
your gut instinct because everyone
except for my husband and my best friend
to a man every person said you're
rushing this too much give yourself more
time and start your tour in summer of
2020 why wouldn't you want to do that
just that that makes sense and it did
make sense on paper I was rushed to the
point of constantly having panic attacks
but something in me and I I you know I'm
a spiritual person I did the prayer
thing and I there was some combination
of gut instinct and call it spiritual
inspiration or whatever I said it has to
start in Fall 2019 I can't explain it
but I can't wait until summer of 2020
and then who was right who was right so
I so I you know for people who listen to
this podcast like I do to to learn you
know what they can apply to their own
lives that's a big one if your gut
instinct e even if it goes against what
everyone else is telling you if your gut
instinct is leading you a certain
direction you need to follow that how do
you listen to it how do you that's
practice that is doing a lot of crazy
things taking you know the motivational
guys call it uh Massive Action so you
just keep doing crazy things and you
watch how they turn out and and that
that will hone your gut instinct and and
I I think it's hard to do if you're 22 I
think your goal would be to just start
taking that action and observing I think
you're young enough that your gut
instinct actually probably isn't finally
honed I I would not have taken a 50,000
bet on my gut instinct maybe at you know
when I was 19 CU I just didn't have the
life experience but once you've gone on
in life and and you keep doing crazy
things and seeing how it works out you
will start to have a very finely honed
gut instinct so you kind of you think
you know what you're gut is saying so
you follow that instinct and see the
results of it and just the more you do
it the more INF frequency or in tune you
get with that feeling you just start to
get a lot of data to put it in nerdy
analytical terms just have this mass of
data of okay I I've done a thousand
crazy things in the past year and I've
just kind of noticed here is how I felt
when that turned out to be a good
decision and then here's how I felt when
it turned out to be a horrible decision
like I should not have done that I was
being way too spontaneous and and so you
just start to observe and and it well
you know what it is it's like playing a
sport I mean the first time Tom Brady
threw a football I bet he had to be kind
of analytical and think about it but
after a point you've just thrown that
football so many times
that you can really go down to almost an
animal instinctive level and so you you
got to Tom Brady yourself you got to
just keep doing it until you can kind of
operate off of instinct and will you
visualize like you actually like you
mentioned prayer and such but as you're
praying will you like visualize like a
sold out audience in theater you go that
okay I'm really big on visualization I
think it matters I think it's really
important and so absolutely I visualized
lines outside the theater I visualized
that the uh you know standing on stage
having a crowded theater because a big
thing I think to to meet crazy goals is
you have to believe that you can do it
if you don't believe that you can do it
if it if that just doesn't sound like
something that would happen to you don't
even set the goal because you're not
you're not going to be able to get it
done so are you doing that every day
like what what is do you have like a set
time to like visualize can you go a
little further yeah I do it uh when I I
I had I tend towards insomnia and so
I've started to use that as a positive
thing where that's my visualization time
all right it takes me three hours to
fall asleep well that is three hours of
visualization and uh and and yeah I'll
go through I'll imagine just different
goals like the other night um I I had a
big recording and it mattered a lot and
so I imagined myself on stage just
crushing I I saw the faces of the
audience laughing I imagined that
footage being on YouTube and and seeing
comments like this is so great i' i' you
know I'd love to come see her live um so
yeah I kind of use I use insomnia to my
advantage that's my visualization time
also first thing in the morning I'm not
a morning person it takes me forever to
get out of bed so while I'm lying in bed
you know hitting the snooze button for
the fourth time I'll just take a goal
that's currently important to me and I
will imagine it in Vivid detail I'll
imagine it happening I mean what what
what does the room smell like that I'm
in what am I wearing what are my facial
expressions who am I talking to like
that level of detail and it's crazy it's
like you you really start to think like
I think I can do this cuz I can see it I
can see I already saw it in my mind so I
I think that that is uh it's probably
the best practice I have is just
constant visualization of of where I
want to be yeah I'm I'm currently going
through that and like visualizing and
trying to I'm not trying I am I'm doing
I'm doing I am but I'm like trying
I'm okay let's visualize me saying not
trying so I will I will like feel the
emotion as well and I'm thinking about
how I will feel when this happens type
deal and I've been doing it every
morning and it's it's tough It's not
tough but when when it's not there yet
type deal and you just do it as like
that's part of your instinct that like I
my instinct is telling me if I keep
visualizing this it will actually come
to reality it it's more uh reverse that
my in is telling me to do this it seems
insane on paper so I am going to
visualize it working so that I can
imagine what it looks like when it works
so it's more like the gut instinct
starts by saying like yeah Jen do it do
it do this thing um and then and then I
visualize it actually working to give
myself confidence that I didn't just
make a crazy decision and I think with
especially something like visualization
is people can think oh I just visualize
it and then it happens but even with
your stand up you were doing stand up in
like your garage with your friends and
family giving you notes on your sets
before doing this tour so you were still
putting in the work yes so uh oh oh oh
ABS I worked very hard absolutely uh a
couple of the things I did I wasn't well
networked in Austin comedy when I first
started my network was in radio so I got
on as many shows as I could but I was a
little bit limited I just had a lack of
network so what I would do is I invited
all my neighbors and and my kids and my
kids friends parents and we would do
what we called garage comedy I'd set up
folding chairs in the garage I actually
I printed out a set list with the the
topics that I would hit and so I allowed
people to make notes I Didn't Do It Like
a formal performance I I would kind of
speak through my set the way I'm I'm
talking to you maybe maybe punch it up a
little bit but it wasn't a formal
performance I'd go through the whole set
and then we would have a round table
discussion about it can you imagine and
but what's so interesting is because it
turned into this collaborative
discussion I I remember one time a uh a
neighbor uh one of the it was a a guy
friend who drinks beer with one of my
neighbors he raised his hand and he said
okay I noticed all the women laughed at
this one joke but I I just didn't get it
there was nothing funny to me I didn't
even understand that you'd made a joke
but all the women were laughing and so
what I realized is I needed to add a tag
to that joke to draw it out a little bit
more for the for the men in the audience
and now I do that and it kills and it it
it was just so helpful to have that um
discussion experience so that people
could go back and forth and someone
would say honestly Jen that one joke was
just not funny someone else would pipe
in and say I agree that I that didn't
strike me as particularly funny but what
if you came at it from this direction
and then the whole garage would say
actually that that could be kind of
funny if you if youd had a whole
different attitude like you're in favor
of this instead of you're against it so
it allowed me to ramp so quickly um
obviously for a comedian the most
important thing is stage time that that
is the gold standard you should get as
much stage time as possible but if you
can't for some reason there are ways to
get 70% of the value of being on stage
it's not perfect I don't do that anymore
because now I I'm on shows more but but
don't give up hope if you are not maybe
you're in a city where there's just not
much of a comedy scene there's one show
per week and it's hard to get on there
are ways around it to to get you ramped
and to get your comedy to a much higher
quality level even if you can't
regularly be on shows yeah and the
pandemic taught me that even like doing
it on Zoom yeah isn't ideal or
necessarily great but you do get like
real world feedback if anything you're
saying it out loud which a lot of times
we just run it in our head but it's
actually saying it out loud that ingrain
it into your brain yep and another thing
I did this is officially the nerdiest
thing that I did and I still do this
actually is I um I put my comedy in an
Excel spreadsheet and I have it I'm
serious I have it conditionally
formatted so after every show I do
whether it's at a dive bar or whether
it's at one of my like soldout tour
shows I I'll I'll go in and so I have an
Excel spreadsheet where all all the
punches are those are the rows and then
the columns are what show it is and I
rate the laugh level one two 0 one two
three and then it's conditionally
formatted so if it's a three it's bright
red if it's a zero it's gray and so I
put it all in and what's interesting is
it gives me a visual of the set so I can
look like I was at the creek in the cave
here in Austin the other night and I I
felt like it was a mediocre show I I
didn't feel like it went that well but
when I put it in the spreadsheet I
realized actually there's a lot of red
on this I mean I got I got more Applause
than I realized at the time I just
couldn't hear it very well because that
I don't know there was something with
the Acoustics I couldn't hear it and so
then to see it in the spreadsheet yeah
I'm looking at the spreadsheet across
all shows and I'm like man when I go
into this one topic it's always red it's
just all like I can't lose with this
topic and then here's this other topic
man sometimes it's zero it's gray and
other times it's red so is there a way
that I can the people who are not
getting it at all and are not laughing
how can I broach the subject in a way
that I can get them up to the red that
the other shows are giving me it's
insane I know wow I I've interviewed
over 400 comedians on here and I I don't
know if anyone has said they have a
colorcoded spreadsheet it's so helpful I
don't understand why people don't do
that it's so helpful because because you
can see it's bringing in a different
sense we're used to using you know our
our ears to and maybe our eyes to
understand comedy but to just have it
just bring in that whole different sense
of like looking looking at it charted in
a way it just it just makes you
understand how your comedy is resonating
on a whole different level and there's
probably fear that there's nowhere to
hide in the data like oh yeah no you
can't hide you can't
romanticize oh yeah it's like oh that
that was a hot bit well it's it's gray
it's zero across all like people hate
this they despise it like I I need to
cut it or change it or something and of
course that's not the only thing I use I
it is important when you're data driven
like I am to know when to let go and
just just relax and be yourself and you
know it of course that's important but
if you can learn to do both you will be
unstoppable if you can get really deep
in the data fearlessly look at the data
and then once you've looked at the data
let go and and then just be in the
moment when you're on that stage you
you'll be you'll just be unstoppable
what's goody hop Brett the verse if
you're loving this episode and all the
other awesome content you get here for
free then you are going to love our
brand new hot breath VIP list all you
got to do to join is go to hotbreathpod
docomo other content like unseen
interviews merch drops discounts
giveaways and a lot more exciting things
and this is for everyone if you're an
aspiring or working comedian or just a
comedy fan that loves getting those
behind the scenes nuggets you're going
to love what we have here at the new hot
breath VIP list so go to the link in the
description or join at hotbreathpod
domcom viip and I'll see you there
speaking of Comedy I've got to shout out
the network behind this show big laugh
comedy they have been killing it in the
Texas comedy scene producing some of the
biggest shows live and also podcasts
like the one you're watching here and
even bigger news big laugh is hitting
the road bringing their best comedians
and shows to a city like yours so do
yourself a favor join their VIP
newsletter and get exclusive access to
not just when they're coming to your
city but also even more fun content and
even comedy news so all you got to do is
go to BL comedy.com
v-b or hit the link in the description
we'll see you there so you a voice
recorder or video like how do you review
your J I do video when I can um so 90%
of the time I do video every now and
then I just there's just no place to set
it up but yeah I I do video as much as
possible because I like to look at um
all of those Elements which is
interesting by the way I started getting
much better laughs when I stopped
wearing like I I would wear these light
silky shirts and um I there I just
noticed I was like when I when I look
back at these videos there are some sets
they should have done better than they
did other other people did well on the
show this is material that on the
spreadsheet you know it's always red and
I I couldn't get this crowd with me and
when I started wearing clothing that is
a little bit tougher like and I'm using
that term loosely but like a jacket
that's a little tougher I think I almost
look like vulnerable or something on
stage when I would wear these very light
silky feminine shirts and I I I actually
am not sure what the what the the reason
is
but video looking at video helped me see
that I think I am looking a little bit
off or vulnerable or something on stage
and when I started wearing kind of
thicker jackets or just any kind of
jacket that looked a little bit more
like protective or something the laughs
went up like people responded to me
better isn't that surprising that is
wild yeah and not okay watch
notice take a look at the really
successful female Comics who have broken
out kind of organically meaning like
yeah they had connections and they were
represented but really I mean they this
was the quality of their content that
sent them through the roof watch How
often they wear jackets like you almost
never see them on stage without jackets
huh isn't that
funny that is so wild just not you'll
start to notice it you'll start to
notice it yeah and I've never even
thought about like I TR I now dress
nicer on stage to come off as more
professional and presentable so what you
wear I think is something that a lot of
comedians don't take into consideration
especially that yeah a lot of them go up
they're looking like they're homeless
yeah and they just think well if that's
your brand that's your thing yeah what
gets laughs I think is um what really
gets a comedian to just have people
rolling is it's a few things but I think
a a real underlying foundational element
is that people feel like they know you
they know who you are so so to to give
you an example um I saw a guy one time
it was just in an open mic um he was
very well-dressed and Ju Just movie star
good looks but his whole set at the mic
was about how he doesn't do well in
dating his set was flawlessly written
great comedy top quality writing great
punches great Cadence great delivery he
didn't get laughs and I think it was
because he was kind of overdressed after
afterwards I talked to him and I he he
was he was quite so I don't know maybe
that's where he he was a greatl looking
guy he was very short so maybe that's
where his like trouble and dating
stories came from but that's an example
of if the way you look does not match
what you are saying about your life
you're going to have a problem so for
some of the guys who look homeless but
they're talking about being broke and
getting no women it's like well that
yeah that you're you're dressed exactly
right you know for your for your
character oh I love that yeah for for
people watching or listening to the
podcast comment on the YouTube video who
your favorite comedians are where they
actually dress how they look I think
mine is I mean Sinbad is the comedian
who really got me into comedy I mean
Mark Lowry is are you familiar with Mark
Lowry not as much oh he he's a story
tell he does more churches he's more in
the church circuit he sings a lot but
amazing Storyteller and then Sinbad is
the one first com I saw on TV and he's
this fun just Wild guy and that's how he
was dressed so it mirrors how he is like
forming and what he's saying and it that
it's interesting how you say it is more
cohesive when you can marry what you're
saying with how you look it comes off
better notice look look at Nate
Bugatti's old clips before he had the
beard and he would like if I just saw a
picture of Nate batsi Circa 2011 or so I
just visually I would have guessed he
was from California he just had that he
was wearing like one of those bracelet P
shell yeah exactly yeah and um and I
mean he looked good like no problem but
it didn't match with the Tennessee
accent and the Tennessee perspective and
notice his I mean I don't mean to say
that Nate like he'd only Chang his
outfit and that was the whole thing but
his comedy had been brilliant for a long
time he had been on a lot of people's
radar as just like the best of the best
and I do think that one thing that
factored into his career skyrocketing is
that he changed his appearance to look
like what you would expect a guy from
Tennessee to look like and I and I think
that really changed it helped it helped
push things over the edge for him and uh
my manager he's a brilliant guy reg
Tigerman he's so smart and he says
whenever you're creating an hour or a a
five minute set anything from an open
mic set to an hour he said think of it
like you are pitching a sitcom imagine
that you are going to deliver this set
in front of TV Executives who are going
to see if they can imagine a sitcom
coming from this standup set and so when
you think about it you're really kind of
showing up as a character in a way and
of course it has to be a character who
is authentic to you it's like Seinfeld I
mean his character on the show that is
that is an element of his personality
that's very authentic to him um but in
order to be that character you know if
you're going to talk about how poor you
are and how you're broke and your whole
family's white trash don't wear a tuxedo
to that standup set you know or vice
versa if you're talking about how your
your upper class and you know you you
know your Ferrari mechanic is the worst
you know if that's your bit then yeah
don't dress like a homeless person to
that set mhm oo I have has your manager
dropped any other gyms like oh oh he's
full of it he's so good yeah yeah he I'm
so lucky to I he's great yeah was that
did you find because that's another part
that I'm very interested about is the
the business side of this game actually
turning your comedy into a business is
something comedians at all level
struggle with and actually find an
intersection between show business it's
show is a job but then the business is
another and you seem to be very good at
both what are you what are you doing
over there joh well I come from an
entrepreneurial background and I have
six kids so I got to make money like
this there is no room in our lives for
this to be an eccentric hobby I mean
from from day one it was like I have to
make money and you know there's uh
there's a great book steal like an
artist by Austin Cleon who is actually
also he's in Austin um he's he's great
and he talks about how it just because
you're trying to make money it doesn't
mean you've sold out it doesn't mean
that um you know that you're not focused
on your art and in fact it will elevate
your art when you start focusing on
money because you have to cut your own
BS especially as comedians we are the
most self-sabotaging people in the world
and when you just start setting
financial goals and you're like hey
these bills aren't going to pay
themselves so I need to start making
money with this comedy your comedy will
actually improve because you will you'll
cut out the self-sabotaging you know
you'll you'll just start taking yourself
and this business more seriously and so
yeah I've I've I take I take the
business side of Comedy very seriously
what are some big mistakes you see
comedians making when it comes to the
business um not setting goals is one of
them I I've talked to there a couple of
people in Austin there are a few Comics
here that I I just think they could go
all the way I mean see it that some
people thrive in clubs and some people
are better in theaters and you have a
lot of potential if you can do both and
I I have my eye on a couple people I'm
like man they could do both and I I
don't want to name them because I have
taken them aside after shows and saying
said like hey you're I mean you got it
what what are you what's your plan and
they'll say like yeah I'm going to be on
the so and so mic tomorrow but uh you
know I'm going to smoke some with my
friends beforeand and I'm like dude you
could be like doing big tours by now if
you would believe in yourself and set
goals so just I think the biggest thing
I would I would say to Comics is you
need to decide if you're Allin are you
Allin and if you are and you say yeah i'
I'd like to do this then what is your
goal do you want a Netflix special do
you want a national tour and and let me
tell you as a mom of six who had a lot
going on in in my life when I got into
this you can do it if your goal is to do
National tours whatever you can do
it but you have to decide you want it
and you have to decide you're Allin and
you have to set those goals and then the
visualization thing we talked about at
the beginning I mean you have to take
yourself and this career seriously but
nine out of 10 comics I talk to they're
afraid to go all in they're kind of like
yeah what I mean they they're on shows
six nights a week obviously they care
about this but they're afraid to dream
bigger than just getting on the show at
the arcade maybe getting up at the creek
you know it's like you need to think
that that's great doing all those things
are are awesome but dream bigger and
let's say you said a financial goal the
is the visualization you're visualizing
it in your account or you're visualizing
like actual money that that's a great
question I I tend because having fans
Translate to money I visualize myself
doing the Deep work writing great comedy
being on stage and just having that
reaction from people like well I need to
tell my friends like man next time this
woman comes to town like we need to get
the squad out like we need to bring
everyone because this is so fun so in my
in my own visualization I tend to more
imagine more people discovering my
comedy and saying wow I love her
perspective that's so fresh that's so
funny like what a great joke that was
because that will very quickly translate
to money I don't know if I'm doing it
right I mean I'm not a millionaire so
maybe I'm doing the wrong visualization
maybe I should be visualizing having a
million dollars in my bank account you
know when when I'm when I'm selling out
stadiums why don't I come back on the
podcast and I'll tell you uh what I did
financially but right now I just tend to
imagine like I I'm just creating content
that is really funny and really
meaningful to people like you said when
you're selling out stadiums as well I
don't say If instead of if I don't say
if mm- no I say when that's why that's
why I was aing myself on trying I was
like I'm saying it oh yeah yeah yeah no
don't say try don't just do don't try
just do we do we can self-sabotage and
or and sometimes if something starts
going well I'll like fear or self-doubt
will creep in I I will start to like
start to whittle back down and be like
oh never mind even though I do I do want
to sell out Arenas I I do want to be
acting and like feature films and I do
want this podcast to be like the number
one where people come to learn about
their favorite comedians and comedians
can come and learn as well so I do have
all these feelings and
intentions and I need to match my
actions with that more it seems like
you're taking a lot of action though I
mean you're here in Austin yes you know
yeah I mean it it seems you seem like
someone who is hustling and taking
action so it takes time as well I guess
it takes time one of the best things I I
really believe that I was prepared for
this whole career because so I had six
babies in 8 years and during that time
that's actually it's when I wrote my
books I've written books and uh that's
when I was doing that but but I I didn't
have a lot of time to work on that I was
busy I I was staying home with my kids
but one of the things I did do and I
could never have imagined how this would
prepare me for comedy is I binge read
books about explorers about like Ernest
Shackleton Alfred lansing's book uh
endurance about Erna Shackleton in 1914
he and his guys got stranded in
Antarctica their ship sank this is 1914
there is no way to call for help and
it's the true story of how they got
through that about uh you know people
who um uh summited the first to Summit
to Summit mountains or people who
survived shipwrecks things like that I I
could never have imagined how this would
connect to Comedy but one of the things
you learn when you read all of these
books about you know the first the first
Europeans to come to to America and just
their Explorations and things like that
is when you're going into the book you
think oh that sounds hard to get to the
top of this mountain I bet this
gentleman will face challenges it will
be fun to read about you get into this
book and you're like I I I would just
quit I mean I would just roll over and
die and let the frostbite get me I mean
this is too much it's too much it's too
hard and at this point I have read like
25 30 50 books where you just you see
what these guys went through and it was
so insanely hard and they should have
given up like 78 Pages ago they should
have given up actually another great one
is undaunted courage about Lewis and
Clark the first Europeans to go from the
East Coast all the way over to the ocean
by what is now Oregon I mean you read
this and you're like y'all should have
died 20 times you should have given up
you should have turned back this is
insane but it really conditioned me to
this idea that when you're trying to
blaze a trail when you're trying to do
something that no one has ever done
before however hard you think it's going
to be multiply that by 10 then multiply
it by 20 and that's that's how hard it
is actually going to be and but it
filled me with that fortitude and that
just tenacity that I would have quit so
many times if if I just if I hadn't read
all those books and understood that just
because you keep failing and you're
facing one setback after another and you
feel feel like you're seeing no growth
like that doesn't mean quit it just
means you're just in the thick of it
it's just hard it's hard to blaze new
Trail mhm yeah and it's supposed to it's
supposed to be hard yeah it is it is
otherwise everyone would do it like so
you want to have the the top podcast for
people to learn about the art of comedy
and learn about their favorite comedians
yeah a lot of people would like to have
that so you're going to have to work way
harder than your competition yes that's
yeah that's a good point if you look at
it from the outside if someone says a
goal like that out you're like oh yeah
that doesn't sound easy that does s like
it it will take a long time everybody
would do it if it were like I want to
make a million dollars in comedy like
yeah we all would like that you know
like we'd all be doing it if it weren't
like the most hellish slog you can
possibly imagine filled with rejection
and closed doors and bombing and people
telling you you suck and Instagram
comments and YouTube comments like yeah
we'd all be doing it if we didn't have
to go through that and now especially as
a comedian part of the job job is the
the social media side that one side
you're like well you have to get on
stage you have to develop and get good
as a comedian we're also social media
managers you know we're also we're
having figured out content strategy and
being consistent with that while also
developing as a craft while also seeking
out paid work it's yep there's there's a
lot of plates and you've em you've
embraced that I love what you're doing
on social media that's how I discovered
you I wouldn't have discovered this
podcast if you weren't posting Clips on
social and a lot of comedians resist
that say I wish it were like back in the
90s when you could just do great work
and and be a road dog and build your
business and I I that's another piece of
advice I would um give to upand
cominging comedians is just embrace the
landscape it is what it is it does
really really help you get your name out
to to post Clips on social and the thing
that I take comfort in is we all
complain about the algorithm say oh the
algorithm it's like not showing my stuff
to people the nice thing is if you post
a a clip that sucks the algorithm won't
show it to anyone so it actually kind of
protects you the algorithm can work in
your favor so just keep posting stuff if
it sucks the algorithm will see that
it'll see that no one's engaging with it
no one's commenting nobody cares about
this thing you just posted trust me it
happens to me all the time but I
actually celebrate that like okay all
right that clip that's not doing it for
for this audience and good like maybe
the people in LA and like you know
producers the Netflix people like good
maybe they won't see that clip cuz the
algorithm is killing it but then you'll
have something that goes viral and
you'll be like okay this is what this is
what people want from me this is my
character this is the sitcom you know
that they can see here yeah and you have
a very defined character I I guess that
could also translate to finding your
comedic voice in a sense
so I I feel I don't know I'm still
working on that how do you have any kind
of like um I don't know Frameworks or I
know you like data structures Frameworks
or anything to help to like for a
comedian to find their character okay I
almost was not going to be honest with
you about this because it's getting to
the point where I'm just going to sound
insane um I have a spread sheet I really
I'm with you am I different okay I put
all of my social media Clips in a
spreadsheet and I see how they do and I
um you you don't have to do you could do
a much simplified version I actually
calculated a ratio of like likes to
shares and okay you don't have to do
that it's totally insane but I um so I
created AE sheet of how all of my Clips
do also conditionally formatted to go
red you know when we have some good
engagement and when it it's mainly
shares actually that I look at I don't
care about views nearly as much as I
care about shares and
um that gave me my character because uh
so I I do have a defined character now
but I did not for for years I did not
and I'm interested in a lot of things
like everyone I'm interested in a lot of
things should I talk about like I was
raised atheist and now I'm religious
there there's there's a funny there's a
lot of funny stuff there so is that me
am I that person am I the the do I do
religious type faith-based the you know
theology sort of do I do that or should
I talk about politics I have some fresh
takes I'm kind of independent I'm not
left I'm not right should I do that
should I talk about I have six kids
should I talk about domestic life and
um what I ended up with actually wasn't
what I wanted it's not it's not the
character I wanted even though it is
true to me um but the data just showed
me people want me to talk about the mom
stuff like that's and and I and I hated
that because as a woman you get very
quickly pigeonholed as not being a
serious comedian like this is momy I
love your mom comedy um so I didn't want
that and I spent years avoiding it and
um and then finally I was like look this
spreadsheet is telling me I cannot did
you got to listen to the spreadsheet and
so sure enough the more I found a way to
lean into what people want from me in a
way that is authentic to me so I'm kind
of that like I I always say that my
natural habitat is a martini bar in New
York like Midtown Manhattan martini bar
at 11: p.m. I mean that is where I
belong that is where I come alive and I
am a minivan driving mom of six in
Suburban Texas so how we reconcile all
of those things is the heart of my
comedy and now it's fun and now I love
my character but I got my character from
putting bits on social media on
different subject matter and just seeing
what's getting the shares what's getting
the comments what are people what's
starting a discussion and I just saw
that there was this enormous need so
many women were coming to me and saying
I didn't know that you could be a woman
with kids and be like that like you are
showing us this third way of doing
things and I mean my fan base got so
passionate when my fans meet me clubs
talk about this all the time they start
crying like when I meet people after
shows very common for fans to start
crying because uh and not CU like that
was horrible comedy like I mean they
they you know of course like they laugh
during the shows but afterwards they
start crying because they're like Jen
you introduced me to a way of living as
a parent as a woman that I didn't know
it was an option until I heard about
your life through the format of your
comedy so that's what you'll find when
you just put stuff out there see what
resonates the marketplace will give you
your character they will tell you what
your character is what's a good data set
how many clips of each topic should one
post to really get a good feel I think
it's going to be different for different
people I mean there are people uh
there's a comedian here in Austin Holly
Johnston I don't know how long she's
been doing comedy her character is 100%
I I I have no notes I mean her character
is locked down there's another woman I
work with she hasn't had an opportunity
to be at clubs a lot she has five kids
one of hers one of her children is uh
autistic and you know so as a Special
Needs Mom she's pretty busy but her
character again 100% I have no notes she
doesn't have to do the social media
experiment she's she she just her
character is so nailed so I think some
people I don't they don't even need to
do this experiment like they just got it
they've nailed it um but if you're like
you like me like I we're just we're not
as clear we don't you know it's a friend
of mine was he was like I'm the funny
fat guy like I'm fat I I like to talk
about it and that's always worked for me
and from the first open mic I did that
was just clear to me and so if you've
got that you might not need that but if
you're someone like us you know you they
a few different things you might want to
go into I can't tell you how long it
will take but I do know you'll start to
you'll start to see heat you'll you'll
start to see heat also live you know
when you're up in shows um when the more
I talked about being Apparent from my
unique perspective the more live
audiences too were they were just waking
up and they were responding to me and it
was like okay this is what they want
from me like they don't want to hear
about politics they don't want to hear
about theology like they they they want
the Martini swelling mom and I was like
all right here's my the market has given
me my character okay cool okay well that
that's encouraging then because I I mean
I've been doing it 13 years and I'm
still like I do I do marriage material I
like gardening do I talk about gardening
I I have a joke right now about how like
a crazy night for me is my wife and I po
a melatonin and nice yeah and it it's
killing and I'm like well that's new and
that's a different kind of laugh I
wonder if it's like I'm an adult that's
an old man I don't but I guess at the
end of the day and that's I guess
consuming a lot of content and learning
things at some point you have to
actually practice it you actually have
to put it into practice so I can sit
here and hypothesize but until I
actually go out and actually test these
things a lot then that's when I'll
really know okay do you want to know how
I would analyze that if I okay all right
so what I would think is what
conflict what internal conflict is this
resolving for people that makes them
explode in laughter when you say that
what What conflict is in their own
hearts that is like oh thank God you
know when you say that I don't think
people want to do anything I don't think
people want to go out I don't I mean
especially since the pandemic like oh I
can be home type deal so the fact to go
out to be at a show at 10 p.m. right and
actually and probably have been drinking
some so they're already tired so the
fact that someone's like oh I could go
for a melatonin right now maybe there is
that feeling yeah you're your fan base
will take off when you give people
permission in a certain area of life so
you are giving people permission to say
yeah you know what I don't want to go to
the club like I I don't want to go out I
like it it's actually okay because this
guy he has a microphone he's on stage
he's an authority figure and he's
telling me that a big night for him is
popping a melatonin so you know what
thank God I feel so relieved that I
don't have to go through this charade
anymore that that I want to go do the
cool things or whatever and and I
started to see uh similar moments when
like I would say um I've had to do I I
would say parenting is really hard I've
had to Google what to do when your kid's
teacher has an anger management issue
how to handle classroom bullying other
than that homeschool went pretty well
and and that always gets a big laugh and
you know certainly for the parents
especially that everyone homeschooled at
one point during the pandemic and uh so
for the parents there's I am giving them
permission that you can just suck at all
of this because obviously like I'm I'm
an authority figure when I'm on stage
and like wow this authority figure sucks
at this like that's really encouraging
and um but even for people who aren't
parents they're like yeah there's
something really important in my life
that I'm failing at
and this woman is giving me permission
to just laugh at it and when you can
start giving people
permission to do what they kind of felt
like they should be doing but Society is
like telling them they
can't watch your Instagram numbers go up
and up and up and up and up so following
that premise Perhaps it is about the
charade of being an adult and all the
things we do that we really don't want
to do yes yeah and that you know know
that fits with your look too like if you
had face tattoos and blue hair and
dressed in like leather and
spikes that wouldn't be believable that
that you're just like I just want to
stay home you'd be like no this guy's at
the bar he's starting fights but you
look like a guy who is like you know
what I just I would like to um balance
my grocery budget and it's like you and
and so many people they're like I'm that
guy too and man he's given me permission
like yes I can just go home and like bch
watch a show and I don't have to like go
shop for like some the latest trending
outfit whatever that you you will you'll
have fans crying too when you keep
giving people permission to be the
person they always wanted to be but they
didn't know it was okay to
be that's a bar right there that's bars
right there Jen man that's how you end
up with lines of fans crying when they
meet you I look forward to it you see
that you see that I visualize I
manifested yes you visualize it
visualize it so a part of finding your
character and this something I ask on
this show every time is ask comedians
about like their worst bombing story or
getting booed or something that happens
what what comes to mind in your career
there's I mean okay I'm I'm a clean
comic female in Austin which is known
for edgy
comedy I have bombed to the point that I
was exploring the witness protection
program like is should I change my name
um you may be familiar with the Vulcan
it's here on Sixth Street in Austin and
there were a couple of times when
I
um I don't know if anyone laugh any
point and this is and by the way an
interesting note on this is I hadn't
found my character and I I hadn't
relaxed into another little tip is I've
just been visualizing anytime I get up
on stage I'm like I'm talking to people
at a party so who party am I at because
if you want to crack people up at your
Grandmother's Bible study tea at 10:00
a.m. you are going to speak and have
different mannerisms than if you know
your your edgy friend who's an alcoholic
and invites you to a party that doesn't
even start until 11:30 p.m. and people
are doing cake stands when you walk in
you can crack people up there too you're
just bringing a different version of
yourself so I I didn't have that Insight
yet so I went up with a very rigid robot
set where I was going to deliver my
lines it was shortly after coid I hadn't
been on stage a lot and um the host left
so I couldn't cut my set to two minutes
which is what I want to do I because I I
didn't see um uh yeah I didn't see the
host um the one of the best Comics
working today isan Amad was he was right
after me he had just moved to Austin we
all just met each other oh that's right
that's no no the host hadn't left we
were doing shotgun but I didn't see
Assan and um but I knew I was supposed
to bring him up and I'd been so nervous
about this that I I I just met him and I
forgot how to pronounce his name and so
and then so then I I I don't care about
anything else I I'm like okay my set's
done like I'm toast this is the worst
thing that's ever happened to a comedian
but now like what I'm like how do you
pronounce his name how do you I can't be
that person you know who's like and um
and I I I just I just ate it for um 12
minutes which felt like 15 hours people
were just looking at me like this poor
woman is she lost like is she maybe she
thinks this is the PTA meeting maybe
this is why she's here she definitely
does not belong in comedy and then I
mispronounced isan's name and slunk off
the stage yeah so um that that was like
it was a like early right after the
pandemic this is after you've sold out
theaters sold out theaters I'm killing
it and then oh yeah yeah no there's
nothing like going up in front of people
that have never heard of you that
because that's the thing when I sold out
theaters those people knew who I was so
it was my F Well actually the other
thing is but that hour was it it was a
good hour I mean that was not just my F
giving me credit that's the hour that I
did all of the um I did garage comedy I
did the spreadsheets and I did work that
out in Austin clubs so it was a
combination of it was that's my special
the naughty corner it's on Amazon it's
that's a solid hour so this was also
kind of some new material that I was
working on but I will admit it wasn't
all new material I mean I would love to
tell you this was my experimental stuff
like no some of it um was tried and true
and I just wasn't bringing the right
energy I I just wasn't my performance
sucked so and I I have a there are a few
more stories of me going up in Austin
and because the other thing is because
I've sold out theaters they often put me
on more in like a headlining role at the
end so I'll be comedian number six of
eight horrible mistake because it'll be
someone talking about the filthiest
stuff you can possibly imagine every
graphic sexual detail and killing like
being hilarious with I this is like
triple it's Beyond art this is like
triple x-rated content but super
funny okay this I I I bombed horribly my
most recent bomb a couple months ago um
at a show up north here in Austin okay
so this guy goes up like he's it's it's
not a clean set you know so he's and
he's crushing I mean just crushing so
then um the host goes up and is trying
to be nice to me and they're like you
guys won't even believe it you won't
believe it we have a headlining touring
comic she sells out everywhere she has
an Amazon Prime special and I had just
done this show at the last minute I was
this was all new material I was just
going to get up there and riff and I'm
like oh no no no no no no no because
this guy I mean the people were
literally grabbing each other and wiping
tears out of their eyes at how funny
this guy is so now when I'm introduced
that way like she is a she that guy
didn't sell out theaters but this woman
does they're thinking like we are about
to
experience the most incred
shockingly hilarious comedy that anyone
has ever heard and I get up there and
I'm talking about my minivan and life at
like the parent teacher conference and I
I just bumed these people like what is
she can we get the other guy back like
why is she here and certainly we don't
believe that she sells out theaters so
um that's another struggle for me and
Austin is clean comic should go up first
and when I'm put at the end of like a
hilarious and filthy show it's I've
learned how to make it work but that was
a big learn learning curve being like
only female only clean comic at the end
of a show that's filthy and it's all men
that took a little studying to be able
to do well in those spots and how do you
bounce back like sometime we could be
super down on ourselves I get drunk I
look I don't have any I'm just like I
complain to my friends I I I have no
healthy I don't I don't have any healthy
coping I I get so mad I I'm livid when I
bomb I hate it I don't have any healthy
coping mechanisms I you have a
spreadsheet for that I know yeah I
should have a spreadsheet of like okay
when I drank the Vodka as opposed to
doing the tequila shots after I bombed I
don't know I don't have anything I
nothing on that one Well I this is this
has been amazing Jen honestly thank you
so much for dropping all this
spreadsheet yes I know I'm here I'm here
with the spreadsheets yes yes I'm so
excited yeah I one of the things I'm
saying in my current hour is um I was
talking about keeping kids from seeing
inappropriate things on the internet and
a fan told me she said um she said yeah
I used to send racy pictures to my
boyfriend when I was a senior in high
school and I did it by edding pictures
in a shared Excel spreadsheet because my
parents never looked there and I was
like is that my Ultimate Fantasy I mean
I'm not a sexting person but if I were
like I mean I think like that my whole
life I've just wanted my husband to look
into my eyes and be like Manel d17 like
w Really I made a chart out of it you
know like that pivot table really
yeah so I uh no I'm I'm such a
spreadsheet person yeah totally 100%
well before we get out of here is there
any closing favorite comedy advice you
have or anything you want to leave the
people with yeah um it I want to
repeat what I said earlier to to The
Comedians listening go all in go all in
or or or or or decide actually here's
you could decide I'm not going to go all
in I have talked to people that they say
I have a day job that I like and I
actually I just want to do mics
occasionally get 10 minutes on a show
and I am actually happy with that I I
don't I don't want anything beyond that
and I'd like to just be a great local
showcase comic and if that is your goal
awesome I mean set goals around that
visualize really killing at at your
local Brewery when when the people come
out to the
brewery but if you want more than that
admit it don't feel guilty about it own
it don't make it excuses I have six kids
don't make excuses and go for it and go
big and make the decision that this goal
is is good and you're not going to quit
and you're going to keep working until
you get there and let me tell you 99 out
of a 100 Comics don't do that maybe 999
out of a thousand so if you do that I I
think you're going to get
there well where can people that heard
this and felt inspired where can they
reach out to you and I have a podcast I
love my podcast it's so much fun it's
the Gen full Wier show um I just I love
that I love my podcast so much I have so
much fun with it and you can see where
I'm going to be on my tour at JFC comedy
tour.com JFC comedy tour.com and if if
someone wants to contact you directly
what's the easiest or best way the best
way JFC comedy tour.com that'll take you
to my whole website it has my assistance
contact info it is honestly better to go
through her because she will make sure
that you actually get a reply cuz I
can't deal with stuff like that so her
uh her name is Caitlyn she is awesome
she's also my podcast producer so just
shoot Caitlyn an email with whatever you
want to say to me and then she goes over
all the emails we talk about it and I
tell her how to reply it it's it's much
much more streamlined way to get in
touch I love it well Jen thank you so
much for being on hot breath yes this is
an honor I'm a big fan so this is a big
day for me thank you so much oh yeah all
right hot
breath